ja einen wunderschönen guten morgen auch
von mir hierzu die richtigen fragen
einem spezial mit spd chef lars
klingbeil lars klingbeil nicht im
schlabberpulli wie olaf scholz oder wie
sie selbst getwittert haben aber wenn
wir uns das anschauen was gerade auf den
straßen in deutschland loses
klimaaktivisten die da den berufsverkehr
stören ist das okay alles fürs klima
naja ich glaube man muss abwägen es ist
total in ordnung zu demonstrieren so
protestieren auch noch ein wichtiges
thema hinzuweisen aber es muss im rahmen
bleiben und ich glaube wenn man
diejenigen die pendeln wenn man die
trifft
würden sie da auch ausrasten wenn da
jemand sieht festhalten würde
berufsverkehr am morgen auch ein
bisschen länger hier gebraucht das hat
jetzt nichts mehr klimaaktivisten zu tun
aber natürlich merke ich auch dass ich
unruhig werde wenn ich nicht stellung wo
ankomme nochmal es ist richtig dass
junge menschen auch demonstrieren das
thema thema klima ist ja ein wichtiges
zeichen wo friedrich merz die
atomenergie wieder in den mittelpunkt
rückt verstehe ich noch mal um so mehr
hat das protestiert wird von politik
aber das ist müssen einmal den ton
weiter aber das ist an dieser stelle
muss man immer darauf achten dass der
protest im rahmen bleibt der protest
muss im rahmen bleiben sagt der spd-chef
viele fragen sich in diesen tagen auch
erkennbar sie sind die kanzlerpartei
wann gibt es endlich richtige freiheit
hier in deutschland
wir alle wollen freiheit wir alle wollen
dass corona überwunden ist wir wollen
wieder zu unserem alten leben zurück und
ich kann nur appellieren an dieser
stelle dass wir jetzt aber darauf achten
dass wir nicht fahrlässig werden wir
haben ein jahr gut geschafft ohne
impfstoff wir haben jetzt ein jahr mit
impfstoff viele lassen sich impfen
leider nicht ausreichend und jetzt
werden wir den zahlen der experten
glauben haben wir noch zwei drei wochen
vor uns in denen die omikron welle noch
steigen wird und danach wird es dann
hoffentlich auch zur lockerung kommen
das haben jetzt seit zwei jahren
erklingen weil noch ein paar wochen noch
ein bisschen warten ich will in ein paar
zahlen vorlesen herunter
oder ob man der statistik der welt hat
mal eine spannende rechnung aufgemacht
er hat gesagt karl lauterbach
argumentiert jetzt 150 tote sind zu viel
das sind aber nur fünf prozent der
täglich 2700 verstorbenen und besonders
interessant die große grippewelle
2017/18 forderte
25.000 menschen leben das macht rund 360
tote pro tag kann es sein dass wir uns
einfach so sehr auf corona tote
fokussieren dass wir gar nicht mehr
sehen ja man kann in deutschland sterben
man stirbt auch noch ich frage mich was
die konsequenz ihrer aussage wäre das
uns egal ist was mit den menschen
passiert und ich sage nein wenn wir
jetzt wissen wir haben jetzt noch zwei
drei wochen vor uns sie die mikrowelle
anhalten wird dann geht der peak runter
dann haben wir die höchsten zahlen noch
geschafft ich glaube da gibt es eine
breite solidarität in diesem land zu
sagen ja diese zwei drei wochen strengen
uns noch an aber ich habe mir immer die
balance im gesundheitssystem weil man
hat immer erklärt das gesundheitssystem
darf nicht überlastet werden darf wenn
sie meine frage beantworten würde in der
tat weil wir viel zu viele menschen
gerade auch im risikobereich haben die
nicht geimpft sind und das ist ein
problem wir haben drei millionen über 60
jährige die nicht geimpft sind wir haben
zwei millionen unter 60 jährige die
risikogruppe die nicht geimpft sind und
wenn diese gruppen hart betroffen sind
von omikron dann wird es dazu kommen
dass viele in den kranken oder das ist
ja ein ewig schleife erklären weil und
uns wurde erklärt und erklärt ganz ruhig
auch einmal ausreden und bürgern wurde
erklärt dass am ende ist darum geht dass
das gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet
werden darf jetzt sehen wir intensiv
nicht überlastet wir sehen dass die
krankenhäuser insgesamt nicht überlastet
sind und sie sagen uns immer noch sorry
wir können ihnen die freiheit nicht
zurückgeben das hat ja damit zu tun dass
wir in diesem land eine kluge kona
politik machen dass wir mit das land
sind das die härtesten maßnahmen hat
dass es eben nicht zu einer überlastung
der krankenhäuser kommt und ich bin mir
ganz sicher wenn die menschen wissen in
zwei drei wochen und das ist ja die zahl
die alle experten sagen haben wir die
welle überwunden mit omikron dann sind
auch alle bereit in diesem land sich
unter zu harken und diese zwei drei
wochen noch mitzumachen dann ist sie
auch das was kann auch mal drei und noch
mal sechs er uns niemand hat diese
pandemie geplant niemand kennt aber
lange laufen bis ja aber es geht darum
dass wir eine andere impfquote haben und
ich sage ihnen auch das was wir gerade
von der union erleben dass man jetzt
eine andere einrichtung bezogene
impfpflicht dass man die innerhalb von
kurzer zeit so infrage stellt dass man
ein wirrwarr kurs fährt wie herr söder
unter märz das jetzt machen das führt zu
einer verunsicherung in der bevölkerung
das ist der punkt wo bevölkerung sagt
wir machen das nicht mehr mit aber die
bevölkerung sagt auch wir sehen nur den
umfragen die mehrheit der menschen will
diese maßnahmen nicht mehr lassen sie
uns mal bei den maßnahmen leider zwei
gehen den geschäften jedoch auch dass
die habe aber vorher eine mehrheit er
klingbeil und wenn wir jetzt den um uns
herum macht alles auf dänemark schweden
england teilweise sind die im kot nicht
wesentlich besser bei uns stimmt einfach
nicht wenn wir uns jetzt anschauen zweig
in geschäften in immer mehr ländern soll
es abgeschafft werden warum sagen sie
jetzt nicht einfach auch der die fdp
sagt abschaffung warum sagen sie nicht
sp2 massen das reicht mehr braucht man
nicht mehr es gibt ja bundesländer die
das gerade tun und das liegt in der
verantwortung der länder aber noch mal
wir haben auf der letzten
ministerpräsidenten konferenz gemeinsam
verabredet dass karl lauterbach mit den
ländern eröffnungs perspektiven
vorbereitet jetzt am 16 februar wird es
die nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz geben dann
werden wir uns gemeinsam die zahlen
angucken und seien sie mal sicher alle
wollen so schnell es geht öffnungs
perspektiven noch schaffen aber wir
machen das verantwortungsvoll und das
was wir gerade in diesen tagen von der
union erleben das ist alles andere als
verantwortungsvoll
die spd war mal die partei der freiheit
willy brandt hat gesagt mehr demokratie
wagen mehr auf den mündigen bürger
setzen warum sagen sie nicht ja jetzt
ist die zeit jeder bürger kann selbst
entscheiden in der korona krise weil ich
es für richtig halte dass wir nach zwei
jahren kraftanstrengungen die wir als
gesellschaft gemacht haben dass wir
jetzt die letzten zwei drei wochen auch
noch uns gemeinsam anstrengen als land
solidarisch durch die krise durch gehen
und dann ist hoffentlich so geschafft
haben dass wir ganz andere zahlen auch
in den krankenhäusern haben auch bei den
toten bei der frage was wir als land
gemeinsam geschafft haben
dass sie diese einfachen über stress
kann einfach über das was die länder um
uns herum maria risch durch eine krise
durch gehen und das haben wir bisher gut
geschafft als mit den härtesten
maßnahmen da sind die steuer hat rauben
die dazu geführt haben dass wir eben
nicht so viele tote haben nicht so viele
menschen auf den intensivstationen wie
das in anderen ländern der fall war und
ich finde das richtig dass du zu machen
er klingt weil ich war bis gestern abend
in der ukraine auf dich einreden jetzt
kurz auch noch über die kehrtwende von
herrn söder über die kehrt werden von
den sünder vielleicht erstmal über die
kehrtwende der spd dann kommen wir auch
wieder auf herrn söder oder die
problematik der spd denn wenn wir uns
anschauen ich es gerade angesprochen
kommt gerade aus der ukraine zurück wenn
man dort mit menschen spricht dann fällt
immer wieder der name gerhard schröder
und dann sagen die menschen in der
ukraine zu mir erklär mir doch mal wie
kann so ein altkanzler immer noch teil
dieser partei überhaupt sein der für
gazprom arbeitet für rosneft arbeitet
der sich millionen in die tasche steckt
mit dem geld was am ende dann finanziert
wird um die ukraine anzugreifen dann
schmeißen sie gerd schröder aus der
partei jetzt schon das teil der spd habe
geht schröder entscheidet nicht über die
aktuelle politik der spd was tun das
gestern olaf scholz das tue ich als
vorsitzender und die spd politik ist
sehr klar olaf scholz ist jetzt in
wichtigen missionen unterwegs hat sich
gestern mit herrn duda getroffen hat
sich gestern mit magna getroffen er war
bei joe biden er legt eine
transatlantische eine europäische linie
fest und die ist klar und
unmissverständlich wenn russland die
territoriale integrität der ukraine
angreift dann wird es eine
unmissverständliche reaktion geben und
da weiß putin was ihn erwartet und das
ist an deutlichkeit nicht zu überbieten
das gefällt nicht jedem auch ein
schröder nicht er hat sich anders
geäußert aber die spd ist da sehr klar
ich will ihnen einmal zeigen dass thomas
kutschaty gesagt hat der fraktionschef
in nrw
spitzenkandidat bei der nächsten wahl
der hat in einem tweet gesagt schröder
schadet der europäischen außenpolitik
hier sehen wir den tweet ein
eingeblendet man muss es so klar sagen
schadet der europäischen außenpolitik
und das was er dort getan hat und was er
gemacht hat sehen sie das auch so
schadet gerhard schröder der
europäischen außenpolitik ich glaube
dass es richtig ist dass sich alle da
dem kurs den olaf scholz den sachs gs
kentenich vertreten dass sich alle
dahinter versammeln und das ist auch das
was ich von allen spd mitgegangen
erwartet und das macht europa stark und
alles was von diesem weg abweicht das
schadet in der tat der einigkeit der
europäischen union also schadet ging
also schadet mir hat schon der
europäischen union die antwort
mitgegeben
was ist das für sie persönlich sie
kennen sich lange sie haben einst in
seinem bundestagsbüro gearbeitet sind
sie enttäuscht davon dass ich schon dass
ich so in diese richtung entwickelt es
ist für mich nicht die einfachste
situation sage ich noch ganz offen aber
für mich ist klar dass ich jetzt mich
nicht billigt distanziere dass ich aber
auch nicht dinge verteidige die falschen
und finde sowohl die inhaltliche
positionierung in russland ukraine
konflikt die ich gerade von gerd
schröder erlebe finde ich falsch und ich
finde das ist ein fehler dass er sich
jetzt bei gazprom engagiert ist habe ich
ihm auch persönlich gesagt dass ich
beide dinge für falsch halte und für
mich ist aber das wäre da reagiert weil
sauer süß oder muss zu persönlichen
gesprächen an der stelle nicht sagen
aber was ich ihnen deutlich sagen kann
ist dass vor allem seine position
keinerlei einfluss auf die aktuelle
politik der spd hat die ist klar dies
deutlich dies unmissverständlich auch an
die russische seite und entscheiden tun
jetzt eben leute wie olaf scholz und ich
und wir sind sehr deutlich dann lass uns
über die aktuelle politik der spd
sprechen oder scholz wollte weil die
beiden immer noch nicht nord stream in
den mund nehmen das wurde wieder
kritisiert auch in den us-medien was ist
so schwer daran da ist gar nicht schwer
da dran aber ich halte es für falsch
dass man einzelne sanktionsinstrumente
raus nimmt und sie benennt ich erlebe
jetzt seit tagen ein wirrwarr wirklich
in der union wo herr söder sagt nuzzi um
2 auf gar keinen fall denn widerspricht
friedrich merz dann kommt friedrich merz
und das geht jetzt um sie sind die
regierung schreiber und ich glaube dass
ein solcher kurs wo man merkt da
versucht eine politische partei sich zu
profilieren denn der außenpolitik aber
nicht in der sache klar und deutlich zu
sein dass das am ende auch unsere
position schwächt und die position von
olaf scholz ist ja deutlich geworden
alles liegt auf dem tisch nichts ist
ausgeschlossen und da kann sich jeder
der das auch mitdenken will verstehen
was darunter gemeint ist nun sagen sie
immer man will sich nicht in die karten
schauen lassen dann hat beiden ja aus
der spd sich einen schweren fehler
gemacht wenn er gesagt hat wir machen
nord stream 29 hat natürlich auch eine
ganz andere innenpolitische situation
der hat zwischenwahlen der ist auch da
unterwegs setzt mit im politischen druck
das kann man nachvollziehen aber ich
halte unsere position an der stelle
wirklich für konsequent ich halte sich
für richtig auch zu sagen wir nehmen
nicht einzelne bereiche raus sondern ist
es deutlich wenn putin diese grenze
überschreitet dann gibt es eine harte
reaktion und das wird man dann auch
genau gucken müssen was ist das vorgehen
der russen was ist das geeignete
instrument oder die geeignete
instrumente darauf aber wir lassen im
ungewissen aber es wird eine harte und
deutliche konsequenz hatte deutliche
konsequenz gilt das auch für gerhard
schröder wenn er sich noch mal äußert
sollte nehmen dann die privilegien als
ab ex-kanzler aberkannt werden na ja die
debatte ist ja von einigen jungen
unionsabgeordneten angestoßen wurden
oder von einem glaube ich sogar da hat
ja nicht einmal die fraktionsführung
sich daran beteiligt gerd schröder hat
rechte als altkanzler aber natürlich
nutzt er die nicht für
für das engagement russ aber wozu
braucht die noch wenn er so viele
millionen bekommen von gazprom und
rosneft deutlich gesagt dass ich das
engagement in russland falsch finde und
das ist die entscheiden aus hecklingen
weil ebenfalls in der diskussion in der
vergangenen woche war nancy faeser
unsere innenministerin da geht es um
zwei themen zum einen um die frage der
migrationspolitik die von unseren
sicherheitskreisen von unseren diensten
mittlerweile scharf kritisiert wird wie
gehen sie damit um ich habe erlebt dass
nancy faeser in der letzten woche jetzt
ziemlich plump auch in die öffentliche
kritik geraten ist durch die union und
wissen sie dass reitzig einen aber was
ist daran plump wenn man kritisiert dass
eine innenministerin oder heutige
innenministerin in einem magazin
veröffentlicht in einem verein der von
zumindest einem land
verfassungsrechtlich schwierig
eingestuft also erst mal fertig ist
liegt extrem einige sogar sehr gut dass
wir jetzt eine innenministerin mit einer
klaren haltung beim thema extremismus
haben beim thema rechtsextremismus aber
offenbar nicht beim thema
linksextremismus haben es ihnen auch
eine sehr klare haltung und wenn man
sich einfach mba anguckt übrigens eines
der gründungsmitglieder konrad adenauer
also auch sehr sparen hat sich aber dann
sehr verändert der wahl wie die union
sich empört darüber ja und dass das
reiht sich ein in eine strategie der
union die ich gerade er so erlebe dass
man sich in einer verantwortungsvollen
oppositionsrolle überhaupt nicht
wiederfindet märz und soldaten er auf
wie die pubertierenden jungs auf dem
schulhof die jeder rauferei suchen also
man sucht krampfhaft den konflikt man
versucht sich abzugrenzen
man ist überhaupt nicht seriös in der
oppositionsarbeit egal ob das nennt sich
feser ist ob das olaf scholz ist ob das
jetzt karl lauterbach und die frage auch
der der einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht sind immer wieder geht die
union auf krawall und ich finde das ist
nicht seriös ich bin dankbar und froh
dass wir eine innenministerin haben
einer klaren haltung habe das in den
letzten jahren vermisst dass das
innenministerium sich klar gegen rechts
positioniert hat ich habe das jetzt
vorschlagen lassen sich klar gegen recht
moment erklären weil ich habe selbst
verstand überhaupt möglich ja das habe
ich ein neuer stern lancer klar gegen
recht aber was ist mit links ist sie da
auch so klar wenn man sagt das ist kein
problem denn so einem magazin zu
veröffentlichen das vom bayerischen
verfassungsschutz eben ähnlich als
linksextrem eingestuft wird er bei uns
mal die spd ist völlig klar dass wir
gegen jede art von extremismus stehen
dass wir uns gegen jede aber warum sagen
so sagen euch das geht nicht aber wenn
sie mal gucken wo die probleme in diesem
land in den letzten jahren aufgetreten
sind dann waren das angriffe gegen den
staat gegen minderheiten die von
rechtsextremen gekommen sind aber ist
die spd auf dem linken auge blind ein
absolut gar nicht aber es war ein cdu
kommunalpolitiker der von rechts
ermordet wurde es waren menschen die von
rechts immer oder das ist ja alles
richtig erklären was ist aber darüber
diskutieren wir gerade dass es zu
benennen und das ist jahrelang aus dem
innenministerium nicht passiert wir
hatten jemand wie hans-georg maßen an
der spitze des verfassungsschutzes
jemand der sich deutlich nicht
distanziert hat der dann zur belohnung
sondern auch cdu bundestagskandidat wird
wo die cdu spitze ist nur mühsam schafft
sich von hans-georg maßen zu
distanzieren ich bin wirklich froh dass
an der spitze des innenministeriums
jetzt eine person mit haltung mit der
klaren haltung steht die gegen alle
formen von extremismus auch fordern sie
redet ja eben vor allem aber
rechtsextremismus erklären weil das das
akute problem in dieser gesellschaft ist
das ist das akute problem was gesagt sie
sehen kein problem damit wenn man sich
reibt er als linksextrem eingestuften
habe ich das richtig verstanden es
probleme in diesem land gibt dann wird
frau feser sich da deutlich zu aber was
ist wenn eine bayerische
verfassungsschutz säugling war dieses
diesen verband eben als linksextrem ein
stück also dann eine innenministerin
dort publiziert das ist doch ein problem
lassen sie uns doch in den inhalt des
artikels gehen da ist noch nichts
verstand das ist eine klare deutliche
haltbar so wäre es ideal werden wenn
jemand dann auch sozusagen in einem
verein veröffentlichen wurde der von
einem verfassungsschutz als rechtsextrem
eingestuft wird und dann ist der inhalt
okay da würden sie auch einen aufschrei
gegeben sagen kann man dort publizieren
sehr gerade auch deutlich gesagt dass 15
bundesländer den vvn bda anscheinend
nicht beobachten ich weiß jetzt nicht in
welchem landes organ frau feser
veröffentlicht hat aber in dem artikel
den finde ich richtig den hab ich
gelesen den teile ich die haltung teile
ich und ich würde sie da also auch
veröffentlichen denn da keine anfrage
aber ich finde gut dass wir in
ministerin haben nochmal die eine klare
haltung hat das hat dieses land
gebraucht und das ist wichtig und die
union sollte sich daran ein beispiel
nehmen zum abschluss erklingt sie haben
gesagt zwei drei wochen dauert es noch
bis die freiheit kommt welche freiheiten
sondern als die experten sagen dass wir
dann die welt überwunden haben und es
ist richtig dass wir in einer zeit in
der jetzt ganz entscheidende wochen
kommt dass wir da vorsichtig bleiben
dass wir mit augen und wann das wann
können wir diese masken endlich
wegwerfen erkennbar wann ist schluss
damit wann haben wir das für sie
wechseln wollte habe ich heute morgen
ist in die tasche weg das sollte man ja
auch tun dass man die masken wechselt
aber ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass
die mehrheit der menschen in diesem land
sagt wenn es noch wenige wochen sind
dann haben dann lassen wir weg alles weg
und dann werden wir kluge maßnahmen
ergreifen die uns feiert machen sie soll
man ein bisschen hoffnung erkennen wir
uns aber wir haben doch selbst das
problem angesprochen es gab in den
letzten monaten viel zu häufig politiker
die sich hinstellen und sagen das noch
und dann wird alles gut und jetzt sehen
wir doch aber wie das virus sich
verändert wir sehen doch was immer
wieder passiert nikon hat zwei drei
wochen noch dann ist der peak erreicht
das sagen alle experten ich hoffe dass
wir dann die impfpflicht bekommt das
dann genug menschen geimpft sind dass
der nächste herbst ein ganz anderer wird
als der letzte und dass wir diese
einschränkung nicht mehr brauchen aber
es bedeutet eben auch was machen sie
dann als erstes wenn die einspeisung
fallen konzertbesuchen mitmachen müssen
und ich freue mich auf konzerte ich
freue mich auf fußball spiele ich freue
mich auf große veranstaltung ich freue
mich auf freunde die man mal wieder
treffen kann also ich bin ja auch jemand
der die freiheit genießt aber ich weiß
eben auch jetzt kommen noch
entscheidende tage und die hacken und
unter herzlichen dank spd chef lars
klingbeil dass sie sich hier gestellt
haben das war ein die richtigen fragen
spezial mit spd chef lars klingbeil
herzlichen dank